a birdhouse that looks like a
surveillance camera and mr spock to puss
it's episode 26 of loot
now here's a perfume designed to make
you smell
like a book
and generate offers a limited edition
life
wall clock it's just like a normal clock
except slowed down by a factor of 61
320 every number represents a year and
it's meant to go around once
in the average person's life
keep your head warm by making your own
knitted brain hat but if you prefer ears
put some ears on your ears
or around your neck or on your finger or
how about a mouth in fact just get a
nose ring no no
a
nose
ring
50 shades of grey learn them seriously
here's a poster delineating 50 shades of
grey and these plates are perfect for
finger food because they are finger
sized
now if you're going to be making
sandwiches use this crust cutter to turn
it into two dolphins and a heart if it's
too early for sandwiches simply be a
serial killer
tuxedo ring
emoticon rings
inflatable cthulhu arm
or this touching little number two rings
that come attached at the middle you
snap them apart so that you and one
other person have perfectly matching
unique two-of-a-kind rings
time moves under this watch's face
crossing the red present line now you
can't see the future and the past is
gone faded away
for lunch carry your sandwiches in
disguise bags
and rock in a rocking chair designed to
generate electricity while you rock
paper scissors necklaces are cool and
sausage neck pillows are even better
when you fall asleep don't do it alone
with these sheets which have a fake
little dog on them to keep you company
the goofy eyes on this clock tell you
the time the one on your left looks to
the hour and the other looks at the
minute this gumball tastes like apple
cobbler but it's just the dessert in
your tv dinner gum set these two are
flavored like roast beef and buttered
corn and these envelopes are fruit
flavored when you lick them to stick
them oh look a bathroom mist designed to
smell like a baby's head
here's a special thermally insulated bag
that's great for transporting wine but
it looks like a cheap paper bag and you
can frighten people when you sip from
your cracked mug full of death wish
coffee a special roast guaranteed to be
the strongest coffee you've ever tasted
both in terms of flavor and caffeine
content
your iphone can snap into this little
guy to become your pet and these urine
sample bottles contain a delicious
yellow liquid candy quiet down the baby
with a pacifier that puts a mustache
under his nose this straw building kit
allows you to make your own custom
straws for mixing and sharing drinks and
these straws give you a kissy face
of course make sure you're fancy and use
these fine disposable paper cups or use
an r2d2 mug or glasses designed to
express each one of the seven deadly
sins for instance
pride
sloth
gluttony
wrath
here's a company that will take two
photos of your head and use them to
print a 3d action figure head of your
face the smallest size can be used on
lego dudes
or look just use this backpack that
turns into a basketball hoop or this
goopy mud that changes color with your
mood and why roll your sushi when you
could pack up this device and have a
sushi bazooka
here's a fun free thing desktop gremlins
offers easy to build templates for fun
paper creations video game characters
books movies he even made a special
youtube space lab paper craft
because on september 13th the winning
experiments will be done in outer space
live
right here on youtube okay finally let's
get beardy
a beard for your apple lavender beard
conditioner beard love buttons
and last but not least a beer da cozy
amazing right well for more cool things
you can actually own i highly suggest
watching naomi kyle's show cheap cool
crazy it's on ign's channel start which
is full of original programming for
nerds like us oh and and
as always
thanks for watching
bum